I've said for over a week that the 2024
presidential primary has unofficially
begun
now it has officially begun Donald Trump
announced last night that he will indeed
seek the presidency in 2024 to make
America great again again
the speech is getting mixed reviews
I love the guy it was not my favorite
speech that he has ever given and yet
from the perspective of strategy and
rhetoric it might be the most
interesting speech he's ever given lots
of people noticed that Trump never once
mentioned his potential rivals in the
race he never once mentioned Ron
DeSantis
no one seems to be noticing that the
entire speech was essentially about
those Rivals guys like Ron DeSantis
people seemed somewhat confused as he
was giving the speech last night that
virtually the whole thing was about
foreign policy China Russia North Korea
as well as parts that weren't about
foreign policy that were mostly about
foreign policy related issues drugs
immigration even Trump's take on
Election fraud was framed through the
lens of foreign policy was framed
through Chinese interference why would
Trump Focus his whole speech on foreign
policy which most people don't even
really care that much about
it doesn't make sense
until you remember that foreign policy
is the one area of politics in which
Governors people like his top Rivals
have no experience Trump's speech was
pretty toned down very few zingers no no
encouragement of chanting no no Mexican
rapists or lock her up or anything like
that in some ways the speech even veered
into the realm of the boring something
that Trump for all his faults has never
been accused of being the guy is not
boring okay so why why did he do it
doesn't make sense until you remember
that Trump's Chief rival is being
pitched As Trump without the downsides
all the great policy none of the wild
and unseemly digressions
so Trump chose to present himself in
those highly prepared remarks last night
As Trump without the downsides
the whole event was planned to a t it
was clearly strategic it may work it may
fail but there can be no question about
one thing
this is no lark
this is not Trump shooting from the hip
if last night's launch was meant to set
the tone for the campaign Trump intends
to run a disciplined race because that
man intends to win again I'm Michael
Knowles this is the Michael knowlesia
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from Henry Knox who
says Ron DeSantis did not show us how
Republicans can win with message and
rhetoric in Florida he showed us if we
can clean voter rolls limit mail-in
voting vote and count votes on Election
Day Republicans can win big a lot of
Truth to that I mean I think it's a
little bit of both I think DeSantis has
done a very very good job on messaging
but it's true you look at what happened
in Florida it wasn't just in Florida
Texas did very well for Republicans Ohio
did very well for Republicans what's the
unifying factor is it soaring political
rhetoric is it really Keen messaging no
the common factor there is the
Republicans cleaned up the the election
issues and insisted upon election
integrity and Republicans around the
country would do well to take note and
implement the same sorts of things okay
the speech last night
was
paradoxically the least interesting and
most interesting speech Trump has ever
given most interesting because it went
was intentionally the least interesting
we knew from the top we knew from the
very top of the speech
Trump was going to announce how did we
know because they announced it before he
got on stage
[Music]
president Donald J Trump accompanied by
Mrs Melania Trump so there you have it
right there from the open it's not the
former president it's not the Donald
it's this is the future president and
the future first lady okay
so he comes on he milks the Lee
Greenwood song You Know proud to be and
American Trump just there totally was he
seemed energetic he seemed ready to go
nice and bronzed vigorous full of life
the guy does not really seem to age it's
amazing to think he came down that
golden escalator
2015. at seven years ago it's a long
time especially when you're up there in
your 70s Trump
seemed basically as young and vigorous
as he ever did maybe it's the aspartame
in the diet coke has just sort of
pickled him and he he doesn't age but
either way this was not a Joe Biden
scenario he came up he looked he looked
pretty strong he looked pretty vigorous
but this was not a 2015 speech this was
not the Mexican rapists are killing
everybody and we need to deport them and
we got to get tough on crime
this was an elegant speech as he put it
in fact he didn't even really focus on
the 2020 election was stolen kind of
line that Trump has been harping on for
the past two years he touched on it but
only a little bit briefly and only with
a little bit of a wink
for the first time in memory China was
reeling and
back on its heels you've never seen that
before
because the United States was out doing
them on every single front and China was
paying billions and billions of dollars
in taxes and tariffs the farmers know
that because they got 28 billion of it
no president had ever sought or received
one dollar
for our country from China until I came
along and we were getting hundreds of
billions of dollars
many people think that because of this
China played a very active role
in the 2020 election just saying just
saying
sure that didn't happen
so this this was an important piece of
rhetoric here because
it shows you one Trump
Trump was not going to focus on 2020 was
stolen
we see that he didn't touch it all on
the questions about voting machines and
the recounts and the dragging on the
count until a week later he didn't focus
on that at all he did focus on
some interference from China
but he did so in a light-hearted way
this wasn't a Madman Driven Crazy by by
having the election stolen from him and
pulling his hair out it was with a
little bit of a wink and a nod listen
I'm just saying okay we would never talk
about that but look China maybe they did
I mean moves on
it I suspect was in that speech to
Signal he's not going to give up on the
issue of election Integrity but he's not
going to let it dominate his thinking
this is a man
as he presents himself who is in control
of his emotions and can even sort of
make a joke about something really awful
that he believes happened
then he focused the whole thing on the
future
for a while he used this phrase and I
couldn't quite figure out what the
phrase meant but it's a really brilliant
little piece of political rhetoric see
if you can figure out what the phrase
means
in order to make America great and
glorious again I am tonight announcing
my candidacy for president of the United
States
together we will be taking on the most
corrupt forces and entrenched interests
imaginable our country is in a
horrible State we're in grave trouble
this is not a task for a politician or a
conventional candidate this is a task
for a great movement that embodies the
courage confidence and the spirit of the
American people this is a movement this
is not for
any one individual this will not be my
campaign this will be our campaign all
together
so
I got I got those moments wrong in the
in the speech that the piece of rhetoric
there that's really really important is
Trump answering his critics who say
you're a narcissist and everything's
about you and Trump is saying it's not
about me this is about you and it's
about us together it Harkens back to
that really brilliant moment of rhetoric
in the 2016 campaign when Hillary had
unveiled her motto I'm with her
and he said I'm with her uh-uh that's
not my motto I'm with you that's my
motto
totally changes the subject even of that
motto for Hillary the subject was all
these little peasants are just you know
uh paying obeisance
and pledging fealty to her her majesty
Hillary and with Trump he says no no
it's my campaign and I'm saying look I
am with you and the campaign even though
I'm the one running it it's really all
about you and Trump finally got back to
that and I think it answers the
narcissism charge
then there was a really curious piece of
rhetoric in there that that did leave me
scratching my head a little bit figure
out if you can if you can
get what it means
one of the beautiful things of the pause
if there is such a thing is a beautiful
thing but one of the the important
factors of the pause is that we see how
bad they've done
so we will be able to do it properly and
it will be much easier everybody will
agree with us because everybody sees
what a bad job has been done during this
two-year period and it will be a
four-year period everybody sees that it
will be much easier for us to do what
has to be done the pause the pause what
is the pause oh the pause is the Biden
Administration which is not the movement
that came in to defeat Trump and Maga
it's just this little pause between the
inevitable
first and second Administration for
Donald Trump it's a smart piece of
rhetoric and it's the sort of thing
we've seen from him before Trump always
pushes you past the set the sale but
this is a point that Scott Adams uh made
very clear in 2016. the Trump he goes so
so far he says listen we're going to
round up every single illegal in this
country and Deport every single one of
them because they're all rapists and
murderers and you say what what are you
talking about he says no okay we'll just
Deport some of them and you've already
accepted the premise that we're going to
deport anybody at all and so he he kind
of brings you along he just plants these
seeds in your mind so by saying this was
the pause already in your mind you've
got this idea oh of course there's going
to be a second Trump Administration yeah
I don't really like this Biden
Administration pause but I'm looking
forward to the inevitable second Trump
term
he lulls you into this kind of almost
hypnotically uh to to accepting his
vision of the future and when you want
to allow yourself to sleep you got to
check out Helix right now head on over
to Helix sleep.com Knowles with
everything going on in the world right
now we could probably all use a good
night's sleep that's why you gotta check
out Helix I have had my Helix for years
I absolutely love it Helix has several
different mattress models to choose from
they got soft medium and firm mattresses
mattress is great for cooling you down
mattresses for spinal alignment to
prevent morning aches and pains and even
a helix plus mattress for plus sized
sleepers are you nervous about buying a
mattress online you do not have to be
Helix has a sleep quiz matches your body
type and sleep preferences to the
perfect mattress for you why would you
want to sleep on someone else's mattress
why you want to sleep on my mattress
well listen don't answer that all right
you want to sleep on your mattress go to
helixsleep.com you should take that two
minute sleep quiz you're gonna find the
perfect mattress address for your body
and sleep type they've got a 10 year
warranty you get to try it out for 100
nights risk-free they will even pick it
up for you if you don't love it you will
love it they've got over 12 000
five-star reviews financing options
makes it super duper easy for a limited
time Helix is offering up to 350 off all
mattress orders and two free pillows for
our listeners this is their best offer
yet so hurry on over to helixsleep.com
Knowles
Trump then came back to
to a theme that he did it in a subtle
way but he also came back to a theme
that made clear that he is not going to
just be running some squishy cut your
taxes GOP establishment kind of campaign
he talked about the center of American
Life
we will defend the rights of parents and
we will defend the family as the center
of American Life
but who would think standing up here 10
years ago 15 years ago that a politician
and I don't like to think of myself as a
politician but I guess that's what I am
and I hate that thought but that a
politician would be up saying we will
defend parental rights of course you can
offend to who would think that we even
have to mention this who would think it
even should be a subject to be talked
about we have to defend parental rights
can you believe this
now you love that bit you love to hear
that from Trump
even beyond the point on family which
we'll get to in a second when he says
listen I come up here I'm a politician
do I have to say that I hate the idea
that I'm a politician but I guess I am
the disingenuous oily slick career
politician he would say
oh I'm not a politician maybe I'm a
public servant but I'm not a politician
no no it's about something greater than
me
Trump comes up
and he actually is not a career
politician he's only been a politician
for about six seven years
but he says am I I guess I am a
politician okay I hate that idea because
I don't like politicians but I guess I
am one
it's that it's that Honesty that I think
people found refreshing even if some
people felt the speech should have been
more fiery I kind of was hoping that it
would be more fiery there is a common
theme that I saw
cropping up on social media even from
some of Trump's critics which is people
saying you know I just I like the guy
one of the great listeners to this show
Brita who we you know there's some
people who are you know they're really
in the the Inner Circle
of the of the DW crew and I saw her pop
up on Twitter she says oh I just like
the guy you just can't convince me not
to like the guy I kind of I was talking
to friends of mine they said you know
yeah just made me kind of miss him made
me think oh you know I remember that
that was nice I missed that guy when he
says that the family is the center of
American life this is an important
statement about political philosophy
because there were two views on the
subject
there was the view that the family is
the center of American Life
and there's the view that the individual
is the center of American political life
and the libs believe that it's the
individual they want to destroy the
family and they want to first break
Society down into atomized individuals
then they want to gather them up into
this sort of homogeneous ugly Collective
the Libertarians also tend to view the
individual as the center of American
Life
because they they think that our
politics essentially come down to
National rights and entitlements that we
get as individuals
conservatives don't think that the
traditional conservative perspective is
no individuals have their place but the
fundamental building block of society is
not the atomized individual it is the
family that's the fundamental political
unit Trump is siding with that
traditional point of view that's not the
that's not exactly the libertarian point
of view that's not the neoconservative
point of view that's not the liberal
point of view that's not the leftist
point of view that is the traditional
conservative point of view and that is
the lane that Trump had success in in
2016 and I I if he's going to have
success in 2024 that will have to be his
Lane as well then he got a little zestir
then he he made some tangible promises I
thought the best promise of the night
had to do with a sort of
oblique acknowledgment that things went
wrong during covid
[Applause]
out of our military and I did I did and
in the first day they put it back they
signed an executive order and they put
it back it was gone we will abolish
every Biden covet mandate and rehire
every patriot who was fired from our
military with an apology and full back
pay
so
Trump did not acknowledge that he made
any mistakes during covid and this was
not the speech to do that
you know just like in a eulogy you're
not going to talk about how what a
terrible a person is well actually these
days people do that there's a horrible
case of that going viral right now I'll
get to that a little bit later but
there's a time and place for everything
in a campaign launch speech you're not
going to acknowledge that you did things
wrong but here he's saying look what
happened during covet is awful I am
promising
we will rehire those Patriots who got
booted from the military over not taking
the experimental fauciation drug so it's
also a kind of implicit acknowledgment
that That vaccine that he's been pushing
for two years actually is not all that
great it's not as great as it had been
sold to be that's why the soldiers
didn't want it and that's why he's going
to not only give them their jobs back
give them an apology and full back pay
so Trump is very good at painting these
images with words it's not just they'll
be reinstated to their posts it's no no
we're going to give them an apology you
can picture this an envelope sorry we
shouldn't have done that envelope full
of cash full back pay just it's just
much more evocative
then he gets to the issue of voter
Integrity in a more tangible way what
are you going to do Trump if you say the
2020 election was stolen and and the the
libs basically rigged it and took it
from you well who's to say that they're
not going to take it from you in 2024
what are you going to do that's going to
stop that sort of thing from happening
to eliminate
[Applause]
H voter ID same day voting and only paid
for ballots
paper ballots same-day voting voter ID
so simple and and
we want all votes counted by election
night
great this is the right answer three
simple things voter ID same-day voting
only paper ballots simple I can remember
that this is very very popular
especially obviously with Republicans
but with moderate centrists even Center
left as well easy to remember very very
tangible and then he the the most zesty
the most flavorful spicy kind of moment
in the speech was Trump decided to take
on the issue of drugs
we're going to be asking everyone who
sells drugs gets caught selling drugs to
receive the death penalty for their
heinous acts because
it's the only way
we don't need any more Blue Ribbon
committees we don't need I don't like to
say this and I don't even know if the
American public is ready for it and a
lot of my people say please don't say
that sir that's not nice they kill 500
people each on average
and if you don't do this in China when I
was with President XI I said president
do you have a drug problem no no no no
no we don't he looked at me like I
didn't know what I was doing no no we
don't because we're very tough on these
guys so this is great I loved it I mean
I I myself wished we got more of that
we're gonna kill all the drug dealers ah
you know that's kind of what I wanted
from the speech uh Trump obviously took
a different strategic attack but I'm
glad we got this in here it raises a
question though
okay now Trump is promising he's going
to give the death penalty to drug
dealers
but Trump's signature domestic
legislative achievement was something
called the first step act which led a
bunch of drug dealers out of prison that
was the whole point of the first step
Act was to let drug dealers out of
prison so it's a it's a total 180 on his
previous position here
how's he going to back it up I mean has
he how is he going to justify that
what is his rationale for that complete
reversal might just be hey I thought
about it or hey I fired some stupid
advisors or whatever
he I think he does have to answer for
that though if he wants that promise to
carry any weight
and then finally he ended on a note
of humility and and this note of
humility I found quite refreshing
I am asking for your vote I am asking
for your support and I am asking for
your friendship and your prayers this
very incredible but dangerous Journey
if our movement remains United and
confident then we will shatter the
forces of tyranny and we will unleash
the glories of liberty for ourselves and
for our children and for Generations yet
to come
America's golden age is just ahead
and together we will make America great
again okay there you have it he says I'm
asking for your prayers I really liked
this moment because
there is a misperception
among Trump's critics that the man he's
just a narcissist and all he thinks
about is himself and he's just the most
ego maniacal person in the whole country
I don't think that's true I think Donald
Trump has far greater humility than the
vast majority of people in politics he
jokes about it he jokes that he puts his
big name in letters and he talks about
Trump trump but he he will give you
little hints that he's actually got a
much deeper sort of humility you
remember one time he was asked about
having a drink and he said you know I've
never had a beer I'm probably the only
president in history who can say uh that
I've never had a beer it's the best
thing you can say about me it's the only
good thing you can say about me and he's
kind of joking he's like yeah I know
people criticize me I've got all these
problems but look I've never had a beer
actually I just don't I don't like to
drink Trump is the guy who leans down he
just picks up the Marines hat when it
falls off his head it wasn't a big photo
Opie I don't think he was conscious of
it at all it's just the sort of thing to
do he says hey can you pray for me
please hey guys this isn't about this
isn't just about me I I you know I think
this whole system is terrible I I'm not
running to get all sorts of plaudits at
the fancy parties they don't invite me
to the fancy parties the people who run
the real sophisticated set they don't
like me and they've never liked me so
I'm just here to get some stuff done
okay I'm here to fix the ice rink I'm
here to fix the economy I'm here to fix
our trade deals fix our foreign policy
so I I thought it was a great dose of
humility uh
if this is the tone of his campaign
he'll be answering his critics he will
be the the arguments against him
uh will
will fall apart particularly that he's a
Loose Cannon and he can't control
himself and he's undisciplined that was
a disciplined speech last night is it
enough to overcome his younger Rivals
who are more in the political Spotlight
right now that remains to be seen now
where can you arm yourself with all the
sorts of facts and arguments that you
need to fight in the Public Square on
your own you got to go check out prageru
you know you can search for hours for
Reliable trustworthy information and
still not find what you're looking for
what if you could find all the
information you need all in one place
completely free well now you can with
the prageru mobile app prageru offers
accurate fact-based content about
politics culture economics history and
America you can access it all on the
prageru mobile app they've been reliably
putting out fact-based family-friendly
pro-american content for a long time now
with the prageru mobile app you can get
all the great content that you want from
prageru such as their five minute videos
short documentaries and popular podcasts
100 percent free download the prageru
mobile app right now on Google Play or
the Apple App Store to watch prageru
videos completely ad free and plus you
will get exclusive access to never
before seen footage from private Prairie
events with great thinkers like Dennis
Prager Jordan Peterson Chris Ruffo and
yours truly actually it's fast it's easy
it's free with the prageru mobile app
you will get all the information you
need to defend what you believe share
the truth and easily become the smartest
person in the room download the prageru
app today
before that extremely disciplined speech
last night Trump had been lobbying some
attacks at his potential Rivals
specifically Glenn Younkin in Virginia
who could run for president could make a
pretty good
good run at it and Ron DeSantis who is
Trump's Chief rival right now down in
Florida and uh
DeSantis finally responded to these
attacks Trump calling him de
sanctimonious
Trump
directly and indirectly going after the
governor trying to discourage him from
running in 2024. here is desantis's
response
one of the things I've learned like
learned in this job is um uh when you're
do when you're leading when you're
getting getting things done yeah you
take incoming fire that's just the
nature of it uh I roll out of bed in the
morning I've got corporate media Outlets
that have a spasm just the fact that I'm
getting up in the morning and it's
constantly attacking and this is just
what's happened I don't think any
Governor got attacked more particularly
by corporate media than me over my
four-year term and yet I think what you
what you learn is all that's just noise
and really what matters is are you
leading are you getting in front of
issues Are you delivering results for
people and are you standing up for folks
and if you do that then none of that
stuff matters and and that's what we've
done we focused on results and
Leadership and uh you know at the end of
the day I would just tell people to go
check out the scoreboard from last
Tuesday night
it's a good answer I'm not knocking the
answer but it's a B minus that's not
it was a mistake to take the bait
I think that DeSantis could have totally
gotten away with 90 of his answer it was
that last little bit where he goes and
by the way check the scoreboard
right I beat Trump Trump's candidates
didn't do it as well as my candidates at
least what he's insinuating
or he didn't do his candidates didn't do
as well as I did here in Florida
why would you take the bait
why would you take the bait
Trump's attacks on DeSantis have not
been playing very well
and there's a rule in politics when your
opponent is hurting himself
don't get in the way of it
what Trump is attempting to do right now
when he's looking at his potential
Rivals and attacking them as is
perfectly normal I know everyone's very
upset at Trump for going after yanking
and going after DeSantis that's just
that's just called politics okay when
you're running in a primary you attack
the people who are posing the greatest
threat to you right now that is to
scientists and people like young as well
though further back uh
all Trump is trying to do is elicit a
response
if DeSantis would just ignore the
attacks
he's the one with political power right
now he's the one in office he can make
himself seem like a real leader he's
just doing things and there's Trump
who's just criticizing him
as DeSantis responds and this this
happens in politics you can't help
sometimes you just get baited into it
but it's a political mistake I don't
think he should he should respond if he
wants to give himself the best chance in
2024 I think he'd be better served to
ignore the attacks entirely
Trump is doing what he has to do to
bring DeSantis down a couple pegs
DeSantis doesn't need to help him do
that though
now how are the establishment media
responding to this uh announcement
I think I think that the way that the
Washington Post in the New York Times
and NBC and all the rest of them
cover Trump
is going to play a pretty big role in
how Republicans shape shake out Trump
versus DeSantis versus maybe somebody
else
they're going to do it because here's a
lot of people watch that speech and they
said okay I like Trump I'm for Trump and
a lot of people watch that speech and
said oh I like Trump and he did great
stuff but I'm for DeSantis a lot of
people watch that speech they say oh you
know okay whatever
and then here's how wapo covered the
speech
the twice impeached former president
Donald Trump 76 who refused to concede
the 2020 election and is the subject of
multiple criminal investigations is
running again in 2024 increasing the
likelihood of a potential rematch with
President Biden
that was your Tweet
headline now this is the headline of the
actual article Trump who as president
fomented an Insurrection says he's
running again
uh sub headline the twice impeached
former president has been eager to
declare his candidacy hoping to get
ahead of likely Rivals and potential
criminal charges I hate him
orange man back orange man is back I
hate him
that's that's what the Washington Post
is saying
and I'll tell you what
I I generally don't make primary
endorsements I love Donald Trump there
are other good candidates too I'm Pro
primary I want them to Duke it out we'll
see how it shakes out but reading
that Washington Post headline makes me
much more inclined to support Trump than
before I read the post headline
because the libs
hate Trump the most they hate him
they hate him more than they hate any
other Republican
and
the media and the whole liberal
establishment we know is very very
corrupt and wrong about pretty much
everything
so the fact that they hate Trump the
most
is a big Mark in Trump's favor
it's not desantis's fault that they hate
Trump the most
it's not hawley's fault or Cruz's fault
or Nikki Haley's fault or Tim Scott or
any youngin or whoever's going to run
it's just a fact they they hate Trump
more they hate Republicans generally but
the just they really hate Trump
and that is a big Mark in Trump's favor
I mean this is this is psychotic stuff
from The Washington Post
this you know three four-line headline
Trump who did this and I hate him and
look at this there's a five five line
headline on this tweet Trump he did all
these terrible things he wouldn't
conceded he's old and I hate him but
he's ugly and I hate him so much
okay I get
when I read that every time I read one
of those tweets it makes me at least
half a percent more likely to support
the Donald other people can run too
though everyone's only talking about
Trump DeSantis right now what about Greg
Abbott
Greg Abbott right now in Texas is
setting himself up to run for president
in 2024. and he's doing a pretty good
job
Greg Abbott just announced on this
important issue of immigration
that he has invoked The Invasion clauses
of the U.S and Texas constitutions to
fully authorize Texas to fight back
against the influx of illegal aliens
this is a good idea I'm glad that that
Abbott is using this kind of language it
is an invasion that is what is happening
that is what illegal immigration is
we're talking about not just a million
legal immigrants a year which is a lot
of people but two million illegal
immigrants if you if you don't call that
an invasion I don't know what the word
Invasion means and Greg Abbott is now
legally calling it that so what does it
mean in practice
he says he's going to deploy the
National Guard to safeguard the border
and repel and turn back immigrants
trying to cross the border he'll deploy
the Texas Department of Public Safety to
arrest and return the Border immigrants
who crossed illegally I return them to
the Border uh he'll build a border wall
in multiple counties On the Border
deploy gunboats to secure the Border
designate Mexican drug cartels as
foreign terrorist organizations enter
into a compact with other states to
secure the Border enter into agreements
with form and power powers to enhance
border security that's not he's not
going to be able to do that the governor
of Texas doesn't conduct American
foreign policy this is why Trump focused
on foreign policy in his speech last
night is because the governors don't
really have a say so that one's pretty
empty and provide resources for Border
counties to increase their efforts to
respond to the Border Invasion okay so
that all sounds good but
where's the teeth where's the teeth of
this you know Ken cuccinelli
uh who's a great great conservative
leader and he was at DHS during the
Trump Administration uh he points out
that Governor Abbott has not in fact
invoked the full authority of an
invasion declaration he said that he's
being invaded but he's not blocking the
Invaders from coming and cuccinelli
points out until Abbott removes the
illegals back across the border and out
of the country this will just be a PR
stunt
and I tend to agree I mean this is this
is something that Trump is going to have
to prove that DeSantis is going to have
to prove that that
Greg Abbott is having to prove right now
enough of the words
I like I like the feisty zesty rhetoric
okay I like Clarity and rhetoric too I
mean that can serve a political purpose
but we need action
okay all the invasion declarations in
the world and a buck 50 will get you a
cup of coffee if you're not actually
taking the foreign Nationals entering
your country invading your country and
sending them back to their countries if
you're not doing that then you're not
really doing much of anything at all
and I suspect this is also why Trump
kind of tones down his announcement last
night
is he didn't want to be accused of just
Bluster
okay you can Bluster your way through a
first campaign but then you've got to
get a little bit more serious and Trump
put a lot of wins on the scoreboard all
right let's not downplay that Trump got
Roe v Wade overruled yeah he's the
biggest conservative win of my lifetime
maybe of the century
and and he's got a lot of other wins too
but that that zesty rhetoric is is only
going to play for so long then you need
results
okay because the libs the libs are
getting results
at the G20 Summit Klaus Schwab for some
reason the head of the world economic
forum for some reason is speaking
alongside the world leaders of the 20
most powerful Nations on Earth Clash 5
came out he said we are going to
transform the world
if you look at all the challenges we can
speak about the multi-crisis
economic political social and ecological
and institutional crisis
but actually
what we have to confront
is a deep systemic and structural
restructuring of our world
and this will take some time
as the world would look differently
after
we have cons sources transition process
politically the driving forces forces
political transformation
of course
is the transition into a multi-polar
world
which has a tendency
to make our world much more fragmented
there you have it
the transition into a multi-polar world
when they talk about the great reset
when they talk about the world economic
forum's agenda
what they are talking about in the
bluntest terms is the end of American
hegemony
the fact that he's even standing up
there I love the way and what we've been
doing in the future is we will get rid
of all of your food and you will eat all
of the bugs and you will live in your
little ponds and you will not have your
countries anymore
um excuse me excuse me excuse me Mr
Schwab who are you who what like why are
you there who who elected you what I am
economic Forum that you will eat the
bugs
uh sir I just want who are you why are
you doing this but he is right
listen just because the guy has bad
ideas
just because the guy is prescribing bad
things for the world doesn't mean that
what he is describing is inaccurate very
often people have terrible ideas about
how to move forward in in to the Future
are pretty perceptive about describing
the present Karl Marx for that matter
was pretty pretty good about his
perception of the flaws of the
capitalism of his age
his prescriptions were horrible but
Clash Bob is recognizing this that there
is a movement away from American
hegemony into a multi-polar world that
is in many ways what the mega movement
is about
Maga means make America great again it's
not reduce taxes again or make us
totally free individuals again or do
whatever you want again or whatever it's
not it's make America great National
greatness
which is a push against this multiple
develop America does not have any power
anymore you know that's that's the the
big fight here okay
and that Trump channeling Ronald
Reagan's campaign line has has really
repopularized this idea of American
greatness now do Americans really want
to be the global hegemon anymore that
remains to be seen on the left and the
right but that is what the battle is
going to be about and we're up against
some pretty serious people you know I
talk a lot on my show about the squishes
the sort of spineless jellyfish Adam
kinzinger
former Congress lady future president in
her own mind Liz Cheney
it's kind of behavior you would never
dream of engaging in or modeling to your
son or daughter and yet the numbers are
in most of you squished this very
morning did you know you probably didn't
even know you were doing it you might be
squishing right now if you are still not
shaving with a Jeremy's razor if you're
still using one made by a company that
has explicitly said that you're toxic
you're one you're one shaming yourself
you were too funding those radical
gender ideologues who wish that you
would just disappear down a drain with
your unwanted stubble don't squish
on the truth switch to Jeremy's razors
and get your Founders series shave kit
today go to jeremy'sraisers.com make the
switch
speaking of an absolutely incoherent and
sort of absurd world view moving beyond
the world economic forum for a moment
the libs
are just Shameless
on this issue of transgenderism now in
particular the libs are just freaking
Shameless
they've been pushing the transing of a
lot of people and of the kids
specifically
so they say yeah we're going to pump you
full of cross-sex hormones and chop off
your genitals and that'll be really
really good and it's actually a human
right to get your genitals chopped off
by some quack doctor and the
conservatives are the ones who say no no
don't do that that's bad that's harmful
that violates the Hippocratic Oath that
is just absolutely evil that's you you
should never mutilate somebody like that
that's really harmful to them they say
how dare you how dare you say that this
is a human right to have your genitals
lopped off and have you be pumped full
of chemicals that give you osteoporosis
and sterilize you that's a human right
and it's good gender affirming Health
Care
until now they're making the opposite
argue
because now some people are saying okay
look if fine if we have to go along with
the transgender Madness and we have to
let the boys into the girls room and
have the boys compete on the girls swim
team okay well if we if we if you're
forcing transgenderism on us and then at
the very least you have to say
that the boys who compete on the girls
swim team in order to not have a
completely unfair advantage
they at least need to go through the the
transition surgery right they at least
need to take all those hormones you're
telling us that they need and they at
least need to you know chop off their
genitals or they at least need to they
can't
if they're going to do it and again I'm
not saying that they should do it but if
they're going to do it then they at
least have to actually do it right
and now the libs are coming back and
they're saying no how dare you that
gender surgery that's akin to torture
you can't force anyone to have that
gender surgery that gender surgery is
horrible because they're lopping off
your genitals and pumping you full of
chemicals and sterilizing you and giving
osteoporosis and stuff
wait wait
that was the argument I was just making
you're just
when I when I was just making that
argument against transgenderism broadly
you told me to shut up and I was evil
and that I was violating human rights
but now that it's convenient for you
now that we're saying okay if you're
going to do it at least you got to go
the whole way now that it's convenient
for you you're acknowledging that I was
right in the first place this is what
the Associated Press has done AP has
said in scores of countries including
parts of the U.S transgender people must
undergo painful complex surgeries that
offer rent often render them sterile
before their genders are legally
recognized a practice human rights
groups have condemned as torture
dubbed torture ID policies leave gender
transgender people sterile
this is a very long article in the
Associated Press about how the
transgender surgery is so awful and
that's why we shouldn't make transgender
people do it
if the transgender surgery is torture
if it is
disordered if it is unhealthy if it
causes undue pain
then
all of those things would be true
whenever someone has the surgery
it cannot be the case that the surgery
is Good Wonderful necessary health care
when someone wants it
and evil torture painful scary
disordered
[Music]
torturous
when someone
doesn't totally want it it the surgery
itself has to be one thing or the other
it cannot simultaneously be
contradictory things that would violate
the law of non-contradiction
but this is this is in some ways the
logic of transgenderism just applied
broadly to
the the very nature of reality you're
saying no
everything only is
whatever I identify it to be
whenever I identify it to be that thing
and when the way I identify it changes
then the reality changes as well
it's it's a way of saying that
there is no such thing as objective
reality every single thing not just my
own subjective self-perception but
everything out there in the whole world
including the surgery itself is just
whatever I say that it is which is which
is a kind of solipsism that uh that
creates a hell for people it puts people
in their own hell and it throws Society
into hell
and it just reminds you too these people
are completely disingenuous okay I we
can make logical arguments until we're
blue in the face they don't care they
are immune to logic because they're
saying that reality is not reality
reality is just whatever I want it to be
that the exact same surgery can be
necessary Medical Care and torture
depending on what I say depending on
when it is convenient for my argument
which is why we should not accept any of
it don't try to find a middle ground
don't say well okay maybe listen we can
Tran people should be able to
transgender themselves after the age of
18 but not before the age of 18 and or
maybe after the age of 12 but not before
the age of 12 or now it's like the age
of eight or something no there's no
middle range just say no
no and
it also reminds us that politics that
only is about consent
is preposterous
can't just be well
that it's torture or it's
affirming good healthy Medical Care
based on your consent no no your consent
has nothing to do with it
consent is an important category on its
own but it has nothing to do with the
nature of that thing it's the same
argument that when a mother wants a baby
it's a beautiful baby when a mother
doesn't want a baby it's a stupid clump
of cells it doesn't mean anything no it
your desires
do not dictate reality
okay your desires have a relationship
with reality and your desire should be
should actually be molded by reality
okay not the other way around speaking
of children
a woman just went viral on Tick Tock
this is so
sad this is so so sad it's a woman went
viral on Tick Tock giving a eulogy for
her
recently deceased father here's what she
had to say about her dad
but Dad please know that while I am
grateful and highly aware of all that
you give in this family I still don't
miss you
when you died I felt like there was a
hole I missed something but it wasn't
you
it was the idea of what you could become
I miss being able to Hope and wish that
one day you turn the corner and see the
world from my perspective I miss the
idea that one day you might help me
fight for the things that matter I
missed my fantasy of you
because when you died it solidified the
fact that she'll never be what you could
have been but only what you are and what
you are is a racist misogynistic
xenophobic Trump loving sister a white
man that is all you will ever be to me
and Dad before you tell me to respect
the dead please remember that you
disrespected and disregarded the lies
and deaths of entire communities of
people with your ideology you told me to
Never back down so I won't you know for
a fact that even against you I'm not
afraid to share my peace you are
everything I Aspire not to be and I
refuse to stand up here and sing the
Praises of a man who was the Paradigm of
white supremacy so I'll take your racist
mindset I'll take your money and I'll
take your advice and I swear to God I
will make this world a better place not
at all because of you but an exact
opposition to you
shocking of course but it really
shouldn't be shocking this is what
happens in totalitarian regimes in the
total state
this is what happens that children are
turned against their parents this is one
of the final stages of family breakdown
when the the regime when the ruling
ideology is able really to crack that
family in half and there has been a very
concerted effort for at least 60 years
now to destroy the American Family by a
strategic political left that has
succeeded every single step of the way
because it met with feckless resistance
from the right the right which which
also retreated from defense of the
family is the fundamental political unit
and embraced a bunch of platitudes about
how Society is really just about the
individual and do whatever you want just
don't make me pay for it and so that
they conceded the whole culture and they
conceded that fundamental unit now
you've got whiny kids attacking their
fathers which is nothing new but to do
so during a eulogy after the father has
died that that really would be
unusual and it's going to become more
and more usual unfortunately and this is
the kind of stuff that we are fighting
right now and so when candidates come up
in 2024 I suspect that the the lesson
that the establishment media wants us to
take from the midterms
even in those states where the vote
count was kind of weird you know and
dragged on for a long time and the
results are somewhat dubious they the
clearly the conclusion they want us to
take is conservatives just need to be a
little bit more conciliatory and a
little bit more moderate meet in the
middle and stop being so extreme okay
stop talking about things someone the
other day I said on this show
that a marriage is between a man and a
woman you know I said on this show that
Republicans who vote for the radical
redefinition of marriage to something
other than what it has been for all of
human history until five minutes ago
should not be in the Republican party
because they obviously don't want to
conserve anything and I have these
people post about me on social media
they said this is an extreme radical
far-right fascistic absolute Maniac who
says this
why because I expressed The View that
Barack Obama held in 2011. I expressed
The View that the current Democrat
president held
11 years ago
Joe Biden and Hillary Clinton same thing
that's how fast this is moving okay
and the the candidates who just say well
we're going to all come together in
Kumbaya that's not going to do it man
people are looking around they're saying
our country is being invaded that's what
Greg Abbott's saying our country doesn't
have borders anymore you've got Klaus
Schwab and the world economic Forum
saying
Germany
bugs you've got the the Educators saying
family is evil and we're going to
redefine the family and don't listen to
your awful parents we've got political
leftists talking about taking kids away
from parents if the parents want
transgender the kids and mutilate them
and sterilize them and now they're
admitting that these procedures that
they previously defended do sterilize
people and they are akin to torture
they're absolutely right about that that
those are the stakes in this election
okay and we need a big candidate with a
big Vision who is not just going to
focus on one little issue or this little
issue or even just domestic or just
foreign policy we need a candidate who's
going to take on the whole kitten
caboodle who is capable of that we will
find out during a primary process
you know the rest of the show is going
to continue now when we talk about a
story that really has fascinated me the
FTX collapse this is the second largest
crypto Exchange in the world it was run
by the second largest donor to the
Democrat Party during the midterm
elections and it's this guy who prattles
on and on and on about what a wonderful
guy he has sent Sam backman freed and uh
he he's he's this uh sort of holier than
now lib this preening virtue signaler
and it turns out he's one of the biggest
scam artists of the century the whole
thing collapsed I don't know anything
about crypto so I'm interviewing Eric
Voorhees who is who is one of the OG is
truly one of the experts and leaders in
the whole Space we've got that coming up
on the member block if you're not a
member click the link in the description
and join us
[Music]
foreign
[Music]